antoine bonjour alors le président
américain a déclaré on vient d'entendre
ne pas être disposé à réduire davantage
sa production pétrolière antoine comment
la russie at-elle réagi à cette annonce
et bien interrogé sur le sujet le porte
parole du kremlin a refusé de commenter
la déclaration du président américain
signe que le sujet délicat il s'est
borné à rappeler la position de vladimir
poutine comme quoi une stabilisation des
cours du pétrole ne sera pas possible
sans une participation de tous les
grands pays producteurs
l'objectif de cette réunion cruciale de
l'opep en format élargi et de convaincre
les pays participants à réduire leur
production d'environ 10 voire peut-être
même 15 millions de barils soit à peu
près 10% de la production mondiale afin
de stabiliser les prix et les faire
repartir à la hausse
pour ce faire les russes comme les
saoudiens sont prêts à négocier de
nouveau à la condition donc que les
autres pays producteurs hors-opep comme
la norvège le canada ou les états unis
mettent eux aussi la main à la pâte et
participe à l'effort collectif
la position de washington sera scruté de
très près au cours actuel l'industrie
pétrolière américaine se trouve en
grande difficulté et la situation est
extrêmement volatile le report de cette
réunion chaque déclaration qui va dans
le sens d'un accord ou bien dans le sens
contraire se ressent immédiatement sur
le cours du baril de brent un indice qui
a touché son plus bas niveau depuis 2002
et même bouclé le pire trimestre de son
histoire
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
attendent donc que cette vision
conférence d'aujourd'hui mais aussi la
réunion des ministres de l'énergie du
g20 de demain viennent inverser la
tendance
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine-gayraud en direct de
moscou